hey I got to tell you that this is not a
commercial but our sponsor Klondike bar
and it says Reese's on it I guess they
teamed up just for that one is that a
peanut butter thing - why do they call
it caramel pretzel if it's peanut butter
Gary goes Breezies peanut butter cups
wheezy's that you didn't hear me I
thought it was some weird way that they
pronounced it for a product I know it's
Reese's no you don't you always you even
said that when we had et in that movie
and we did it's racist you've always
said reason I'm not you always say reezy
hundred bucks you're onyx I've heard him
say Reese's a million times I've heard
you say it even in your personal life I
don't say it's Reese's yeah your
favorite cartoon was Baba looey and you
said Baba Booey and your favorite candy
is Reese's and you said reesy
I think he's thinking Reese's monkey
rhesus monkey dude everyone in here was
laughing at you yeah I'll go I'll go
searching through our archives because I
need the 500 bucks yeah what why would
Baba looey be Baba Booey no one in one
is two and I'm telling you twice you
dopey these bowls Reese's Bowl I want
Weezy
[Applause]
claim same reason
you have Reese's okay well why can't
repeat any idiotic thing you know your
breath smells like feces both your
lazy's Klondike bar easy peasy booth
yes Ralph you know it is Gary loves to
talk so much he doesn't look like think
before he talks he just blurt stuff out
like please ease now you don't know you
don't know me
he's there I know you I love you but
again Lisa Jake I just yelled at least a
teach comes in my office she goes what
happened was you you combine Reese's and
pcs that's not what [ __ ] happened no
you said Reese's before you said it to
me in private
absolutely positive I'm telling your ro
heard you say we you see you're looking
for an angle on something but it's not
there I've never said it I've heard you
swearing a life my kids and I know you
can't prove it cause it just never
happened telling you I hear you you know
you just may don't say business you just
I'm now you say Reese's you just make
[ __ ] up because it helps move the baby
is saying you don't you have that tape
because somebody effect I'm almost
didn't want them why would you say
because I thought that maybe they called
it a different you don't mean in other
words it's one of those goofy names that
klondike made up like I've heard you say
bow your that's a lie
no really have it I really have no the
funny thing is you really give me a lie
detector I've heard you say really
haven't heard me say it before but now
you can't turn back cause you look
fuller no I I will turn I will apologize
to you if I'm wrong but I'm not really
have it I've heard you say Reese's you
have not you've said it a million times
I have not in fact we did a show once
where we put Reese's Pieces on the floor
and I remember you saying to me both
will cheese be seized first of all I
don't remember that show yeah I do and
and it's just that it's just not a
listener I
you have selective memory but you have
selective memory I guess I'm wrong okay
every dollar is Reese's Baba Booey
what's your favorite cartoon character
Bugs Bunny no we know it's Baba looey
Baba Booey and you swore you you cause
you're mine there's no doubt that that
we're out and you thought it was Reese's
I know it's not Reese's it's okay it's
just you know Larry forget it why [ __ ]
with your bit right all right okay
thanks care oh good all right you can
leave now
[Laughter]
[Music]